[Applause]
what hi we're back here thank you for
that why are you so afraid of the cards
fewer questions more questions you work
last viewer why is that more scary than
me okay SE Cupp do you still beat their
wife no mayor Pete oh that's what we're
gonna call your mayor Pete that's yeah
given your work in South Bend do you
think there needs to be national reform
for every Police Department in America
absolutely I mean you know we're a
diverse community I'm not sure everybody
realizes that because they think a Notre
Dame they assume it's a racially
homogeneous college town but I remember
yeah
we're not Irish but we're about 45
percent non-white and I got to tell you
it makes life harder for every resident
of a minority neighborhood and every
police officer when there was a kind of
veil of mistrust between communities of
color and the officers sworn to keep
them safe now under the Obama
administration I had a lot of resources
I could look to from a department of
justice that was committed to helping us
without is called the task force on 21st
century policing my police chief would
participate and when you have a DOJ that
doesn't seem to care about these things
right that makes it a lot harder for
mayors and police chiefs across the
country trying to make sure we modernize
our departments and and build up that
trust makes it harder for us to do our
job or there's the Trump answer which is
be rough with them and the people with
the bullets are on my side yeah I mean
it really is we have to keep reminding
ourselves how disgusting that is well
what a violation of our norms that is
for him to say I've got the police yes
what do you might have to be the
president and we also have to remember
this is again what dictators do they get
the people the tough people with the
bullets on their side and they buy them
off that's why the Pentagon budget keeps
going up that's why he's always kissing
the ass of the cops you know because
when push comes to shove and he loses
the election and he wasn't leave the
White House he's got the tough people
next question
andrew sullivan what do you anticipate
will happen with brexit oh you're you're
in a bigger mess than we are I think my
if I would be a fool to predict it's
like minute by minute now
and it's Tory Party politics now so it's
all about the factions within
conservatism but the truth is I think
they're gonna crash out without a deal
they don't want to but in some ways it's
inevitable basically you had you have a
52-48 decision in the referendum right
so right down the middle really on a
very fundamental question and a prime
minister comes in who didn't want that
who actually voted to remain and she
says well look okay let's do a
compromise let's have yeah we'll get out
for the 52 but for the 48 will keep our
trade and we'll try and keep the Econo
economic connections and not being a
member of the EU and so the the Tories
say look that means we're still obeying
their laws but we don't even get to say
them anymore so it's worse than staying
in I think they have to just get out
they're gonna have to see a mess it is
and then they'll have another vote in
five years after so many people have
been hurt and they'll get them that's
what's gonna happen it'd be very hard to
go back into EU once you've left really
yeah I think money can throw money at a
problem it goes away I learned that
what's good you know let's see what
happens to the British economy okay I
mean may not do you as bad as they think
and look the British voted this way
they're pragmatic they they don't want
their issues immigration to and when a
pragmatic country like that is doing
this something is crazy we got to
address the question
okay so representatives Larkin as a
freshman number of Congress what's your
perspective on the divisions between
progressives and moderates within the
Democratic ya party you are much more
representative of the 40 who won in
November 19 than the ones we hear about
yeah I mean I think the story of the
2018 elections was you know people who
appeal to a broad base of people trusted
the voters spoke to them went out asked
for their vote and talked about the
issues that they cared about not so much
about Donald Trump every day he's he's
doing his own thing on his own that's
what won the elections but I think the
drama that people have been focusing on
is a little overplayed I think it's like
people like that story
it is extremely exciting to be a part of
this freshman class you walk in it is a
different breed we have a fire lit under
us and I think of it like a platoon I
worked alongside the military my whole
life you have a platoon but everyone has
different jobs you have the same mission
everyone has different jobs it's every
warm over the guy from Brooklyn and the
Jewish guy okay I seek up are you
worried about Trump's nomination of
Stephen Moore is he booked soon will be
nice to the fed board I mean he himself
said I don't know what I'm doing yeah
that's a steep learning curve and boy
that's what you want on the Fed board
someone new needs a steep learning curve
it's no surprise with best people really
loves he gets the best people hunt
autocracy and you know we're good people
but we're not all experts well on
everything and we probably shouldn't all
be put at State Department or gonna fund
it is a generous term he's a guy on TV
sure Trump sees people on TV right hires
them yeah I think it's a date it's a
dangerous standard just that and I think
that's reach can you explain what you
think happened with the Jesse smollett
case no it's dumbfounded look you know
initially you had a very serious
allegation of a hate crime and then you
know you want to make sure that you
understand what the facts are and then
you have the police department and the
prosecutor's office there you know
really passionately bringing their case
and you've seen that before
and then a few weeks later you have what
we just saw in the last week where the
prosecutor's office just dismisses
everything walks away and usually that's
done in conjunction with and you know
there's a consensus with the police
department and the police department
chief excoriates the prosecutors for
dropping the case and as far as I can
tell no facts changed from the time they
brought the prosecution and the time
they drop the prosecution I've spent
most of my adult life as a prosecutor
doing cases or overseeing cases and I've
never seen anything like that so I think
it's important to understand what
happened because I don't get it and this
used to be my business
if he's still saying he told the truth
all along it's drug that is filters down
but when the top guy in the country says
you can just say anything it filters
down NAACP Image Award ya Sunday night
right that's okay uh congresswoman
slaughter do you think Trump has a good
shot at winning Michigan again in 2020
and all that's the same question to you
about Indiana but he he goes to Michigan
a lot I heard that was his 18th trip
yeah and we're gonna see him a lot
I'm he was here yesterday it was there
yesterday we're gonna see him a lot I
think that this is the Democrats
election to lose and that means it's
still possible to lose I think it
depends on who we put up and I think it
depends on whether we have someone who
speaks to people on the things that are
gonna affect their pocketbooks and their
kids and it's not it is not playing to
the base every day it's remembering that
you have to appeal to a broad-based of
people based on values I won with a lot
of Republican women who have the same
exact values that I did caring about
your community caring about your kids
wanting empathy those are shared
American values
I am extremely optimistic after running
for office for 18 months I'm the most
optimistic person probably here because
every day I'm with wonderful decent
people who still care about this country
and to me if you get a candidate who
speaks to that and can show some
integrity and authenticity right then
you're gonna get a Democratic mayor
[Applause]
what do you think about Indiana 2020
look it's a very conservative state but
it can be done I mean I think about just
mathematically there must be a lot of
people in my County who voted for Obama
and Trump and pence and me so what that
tells you is people are not as
ideological as you right right you know
I don't think anybody would have guessed
that in the last 50 years still since
LBJ the only Democrat who turned Indiana
blue not Clinton not Carrie it was Obama
in 2008 so to me that that tells you
that there is a way to do it I think as
Alissa says it's largely about values
and demonstrating sometimes even people
with different values than yours if they
just know that values are what motivates
you yes they will give you a lot of
credit for that everybody is always
changing faster than we think in some
ways look at gay marriage yeah I mean
this was not even close like 15 years
ago but you know why because we talked
to people we we actually made the
persuasive case we didn't tell them they
were because we also told them what well
it was a Will and Grace
Hollywood change people's minds I really
think that yeah but if you run the
tactic the tactic never confrontational
right tactic was always look we have our
families in common we're just like you
we have your other than and so you
engaged
whereas now the thing is your race is
European I don't want to be part of you
and and but please vote for me if you
are if you or the can if you are the
candidate
I mean it's Donald Trump gonna leave
that issue alone I can't see that I
doubt it no what do you think he would
say what's the nickname don't know I'm
not imaginative enough to figure out
what yeah but you know I'm not that
worried about it no you shouldn't you
know you you're you're the one white guy
on the Democratic side who has minority
cred
Provine ever comes up okay all right
Thank You Roberto see you
[Applause]
you